on Thursday counselor to the president
Kellyanne Conway appears to have
violated federal ethics rules when she
told the American people by Ivanka
Trump's line of clothing when she
appeared on fox and friends on the
morning show this relates to nordstrom
choosing to drop Ivanka Trump's closing
line they said it wasn't a political
decision but it just wasn't really
selling well and here's Kellyanne Conway
on Fox News and they're using her who's
been a champion for women empowerment
women in the workplace to get to him
should I think people can see through
that we go by evanka stuff is when I
would time with each other and I go get
somethin on myself today there is that
hashtag by Ivanka right now but there is
an ethics rule which prohibits federal
employees from using public office to
endorse a product and Kellyanne Conway
endorsed the president daughter's
product no less and in the interview she
tried to shame Nordstrom for
discontinuing the products just like
Trump did remember Donald Trump sending
out a tweet a few days ago saying my
daughter Ivanka has been treated so
unfairly by nordstrom she is a great
person always pushing me to do the right
thing aren't there more important things
for Donald Trump is advisors to discuss
than Ivanka's clothing line but
Kellyanne Conway choosing to go even
further on fox and friends take a look
yes this is just it's a wonderful line I
own some of it I fully I'm going to just
give it I'm going to give a three
commercial here go buy it today
everybody need to find it online re
commercial Kellyanne that's what we call
against the law take a look at this this
is a text from the the 26 to 26 26 35 70
to use of public office for private gain
which says that an employee shall not
use his public office for his own
private gain for the endorsement of any
product service or enterprise or for the
private gain friends relatives or
persons with whom the employee is
affiliated in a non-governmental
capacity there's no real clearer
endorsement than Kellyanne saying I'm
going to give a free commercial here
go buy it today everybody the White
House has not responded to a request for
comment on this yet again another item
on that list of questionable practices
by the Trump administration and
separating Trump's businesses from Trump
is president now some must might say oh
well she was just joking it wasn't meant
in a serious way but that's absolutely
ridiculous she is trying to help Ivanka
Trump's business here and whether this
is a joke or not actually doesn't matter
Pat yeah absolutely not because I mean
the damage has been done she gave the
advertisement and I think people who are
Trump supporters are going to go out and
buy Ivanka Trump's products oh Emily you
know you have a situation where the
president of United States is directly
helping his family out this is what we
suspected all along Sean Spicer asked
about this here's how he responded when
asked about the Kelly an endorsement do
you believe that she crossed an ethical
on Kellyanne had been counseled and
that's all we're going to go she's been
counseled on on that subject and and
Bess that's it yeah she's been counseled
listen even Republican jason Chaffetz
says that they need to do an
investigation into this when Republican
jason Chaffetz says that a Republican
messed up you know it's serious and by
the way sears and kmart have chosen to
drop Trump products that one because of
a successful public backlash and
boycotts they discontinued Donald
Trump's line of furniture yeah next what
we'll see Kellyanne show up on Chris
Wallace's show Fox News Sunday to talk
about how comfortable Trump couches are
something like that she recommends
everybody by them you gotta love how
Kellyanne Conway's title is counselor to
the president and on this issue she had
to be counted on he's the one who needs
to be counseled rather than the one
giving out the advice this is why we
should be boycotting the Trump family's
goods and services because it actually
works and clearly it really angers Trump
join us on reddit our discussion forum
at david pakman.com slash r ed di t
today's show is brought to you by
godaddy where you can buy your own
domain name build a website or use any
of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save thirty percent at try godaddy.com
/ David godaddy has actually been the
official host of the david pakman show
website for many many many years the 24
7 customer support has been a very good
thing for us I've called them at really
odd times when we've had website issues
and they are always available they are
the largest domain registrar and whether
you have a new idea you're an
established business you're creating a
personal website or moving your large
enterprise site over to godaddy they can
do it all 13 million customers try it
and get thirty percent off at try
godaddy.com / david